سنه المساله مش خلاف المساله
[موسيقى]
ايديولوجي هو احنا كان الصوت واضح من
الاول كان صوت كان في مشكله في الص اهه
يعني بس يعني الصوره اللي انا قلته ده
اتسمع اه ماشي الحال فهو مش خلاف
ايديولوجي جزء منه خلاف ايديولوجي لكن
بصراحه الحال هي برض خلاف مصالح مصالح
للمسؤولين في فتحه و مصالح للمسؤولين في
في حماس
ا بدون ما يحصل تصالح ما بين مش حماس يعني
فصائل المقاومه المختلفه يعني زي الجهاد
وحماس وغيرها وفتح من ناحيه انيه او منظمه
التحرير
في مواجهه الفصائل اللي مش منضمه لمنظمه
التحرير انت بتسالني حضرتك ايهم اقرب
الاثنين كانوا مع بعض يبقوا بشكل جيد جدا
لكن في المرحله ديت احنا عندنا فتح بصراحه
لا تفاوض وحماس قبل 7 اكتوبر لم تكن تقاوم
وكان في حاله
تكلس القضيه يخدمها الاثنين ان يكون في
جود جاي ان باد جاي ان تكون
فتح بتبقى بتحاول تفاوض وتحاول تحقق مكاسب
على مائده المفوت ويكون دايما في
تهديد وضغط على الاسرائيليين متمثلا في
حماس والجهاد والجبهه الديمقراطيه والجبهه
الشعبيه الى اخره
يعني انما بالمناسبه يعني لو كان ولابد من
وجود يا فتح يا حماس فالاجابه الصادمه
للكثيرين يبقى حماس الحقيقه لان انه منهج
فتح لسنوات طويله لم ياتي باي نتيجه يعني
ده انا عارف ان هذ قضيه مثيره للجدل ولكن
يعني اذا كان ولا
بد اول زيكو يا اهلا وسهلا اخونا زيكو ما
مصداقيه خبر نقل سكان غزه الى جمهوريه
الكونغو
الديمقراطيه الخبر مش كده الخبر ان هناك
تفاوض بين اسرائيل وجمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه قبال عدد من الاهالي غزه هذا
خبر صحيح وده مش محل شك يعني او يعني
بمعنى اصح ان هو ليس محل انكار وموجود في
صحف
اسرائيليه محل ثقه وموجود مع دول اخرى
اسرائيليه قالت لن نذكرها الان انما في
دول اعلنت يعني كندا واستراليا قالوا لا
نمانع في استقبال عدد من الفلسطينيين اللي
لهم اهالي مثلا موجودين في كندا او في
استراليا او تحت اسباب او يعني يكون في
اسباب تخلينا نستقبلهم احنا مرحبين بس
حاطين ضوابط يعني ممكن دول ثانيه
تفتح يعني ابوابها ولكن في النهايه دي
هتكون بضعه الاف حتى الان المؤشرات بتقول
ان هم بضعه الاف دول ما يحلو مشكله
اسرائيل او ما يعملوش تغيير جوهري في
القضيه يعني السلام عليكم طبعا السؤال
الكونغو ده كان
حسام وعليكم السلام حياكم الله احمد بلال
شكرا مساء الخير ما هو المغزى من التصريح
الاخير للفرو مع قناه روسيا اليوم ان
اسرائيل وروسيا تخوضان حربا متشابهه هدفها
القضاء على النازيه ونزع
سلاحها هل هو تبديل الموقف الروسي لغايه
ما ام ما الذي خدعنا انا لم اسمع
التصريحات يا اخونا فسامحني لا استطيع
التعليق ولكن انا عارف يعني انا اقدر اقول
لك الموقف الروسي بصفه عامه ولو انك انت
بتسال هل في تغير ولا لا فواضح ان انت
فاهم الموقف الروسي فما فيش داعي ان انا
اصدع بما لم تسال عنه انما
ا حتى قبل هذا التصريح الذي لم اسمعه
الموقف الروسي علاقته علاقه روسيا
باسرائيل علاقه توترت رغم ان هي كانت
علاقه ساوند وقويه وجيده يعني وبدون
التوتر او بدون مواقف متشنجه بين اسرائيل
وروسيا هو مصلحه روسيا كانت ان هي
لمصالحها تدعم في هذه المرحله حماس
وتستغل الازمه على مستويات متعدده
لمصلحتها اذا كان حضراتكم عاوزين تعرفوا
ما هي مصالح روسيا انا تحت امركم واذا كان
يعني مش عاوزين فممكن لاحقا يعني تشوفوا
حلقه الحسابات الدوليه المختلفه من حرب
غزه ودي تقريبا من حوالي
شهر كيف ترى الوضع في الجزائر حاليا وما
رايك في المستقبل يا اخونا باكستر موري
هذا سؤال مفتوح جدا جدا فلو سالت عن نقطه
معينه انت بتتكلم على دوله كبيره فيها
اعتبارات مختلفه انما فيما يتعلق
بالاقتصاد يعني اللي هو ممكن يبقى يعني
قضيه
عاجله الجزائر عندها امكانيات كبيره اهلها
قبل غيرهم بيقروا بانها لم تستغل على
النحو المامول الجزائر محتاجه تنفتح اكثر
على دول العالم وتسن تشريعات تسمح بتحفظ
مصالحها طبعا
وتسمح باكبر عدد ممكن من المستثمرين في
الطاقه وفي الصناعه وفي الزراعه وفي
السياحه ان تاتي اليها هذا لم يحدث في كل
السنوات الماضيه اعلن انه هيحصل لكن حتى
الان في حدود معلوماتي ان الخطوات ماشيه
بطيء هذا ما اعلموا يعني هل التعاون بين
مصر والصومال سيفيد مصر في سد
النهضه
موضوع سد النهضه ده بقى
يعني مش عارف يعني التعاون مصر مع الصومال
مع اي دوله من دول حوض النيل او غير حوض
النيل القريبه يعني الصومال ليست من دول
حوض النيل طبعا من كل الدول الافريقيه
طبعا بيعزز مصالح مصر وموقفها ولكن
الحقيقه الموقف في موضوع سد
النهضه
يعني مربك لانه احنا بنتكلم على مل وسد تم
تشييده حتى وان كان متعثرا كمشروع لتوليد
الكهرباء في اثيوبيا ولكن
الضرر اللي مصر كانت تخشاه وقع الجزء
الاكبر منه
ف المساله كلها متوقفه على حسن نوايا
الاثيوبيين تجاه مصر
الخيار جدا وبالتالي والمفاوضات متعثره
منذ
سنوات فيبدو انه المساله مجرد مفاوض مضات
مع الجانب الاثيوبي زي المفاوضات
الفلسطينيه مع الجانب الاسرائيلي مفاوضات
من اجل المفاوضات يعني طبعا امل ان يكون
في
انفراجه
نتمنى لابد من تغيير جذري لعقل الجيوش
العربيه بركان هناك مشكله في البث ما
المشكله يا شباب الكبل اللي كان موق ده يا
جون في صديق ن لينا هنا سناء بتقول في
مشكله في
البث انت يا سناء دلوقتي في مشكله رد عليك
اين انت يا استاذ سيد صفاء اين انا من ايه
يا صفاء انا موجود والحمد لله هل
الاشتراكيه التي طبقها زعيم جمال عبد
الناصر رحمه الله كانت سببا في ازمه
مصر لا يعني برض ده نوع من الاسئله اللي
هي بتبقى عاوزه يعني ايه سؤال ضخم جدا جدا
ازمه مصر لازم تحددها ازمه سياسيه ولا
ازمه اقتصاديه مادام يعني ما هو جوانب
كتيره مصر بلد كبير عنده ازمات سياسيه
وعنده ازمات اقتصاديه والازمات دي ازمات
مركبه
ومتراكم انما جمال عبد الناصر زي اي زعيم
كانت له انجازات وكانت له اخفاقات
الانجازات كانت كبيره والاخفاقات كانت
كبيره جدا ما في شك طبعا
انه يعني طبعا اخفاقات جمال عبد الناصر
ممكن نتكلم عنها كثير جدا وانجازات ممكن
نتكلم عليها كثير انما هو ترك البلد وكانت
طبعا البلد عندها مشاكل في ارض
محتله
بقت اجنده الرئيس اللي بعده السادات انه
لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت المعركه و من
سنه 70 يعني من بعد وفاه جمال عبد الناصر
لغايه مثلا 74 و75 الكلام كله للمعركه وكل
مقدرات مصر راحت للمعركه بعد اتفاقيه
السلام كان تثمن اتفاقيه السلام في 78 و79
واحد اسباب اتفاقيه السلام وفقا للسادات
انه مصر كانت خلاص بنك ربت يعني شبه افلست
يعني بسبب تكاليف الحروب المتواليه كان
اتفاقيه السلام ادت الى قطيعه بين مصر
ومعظم الدول العربيه بقرار من الدول
العربيه باستثناء ثلاث او اربع دول عربيه
فقط قطعت مصر ولم تعود العلاقات الا في
سنه 89 وبرده فضلت المسائل بعد مقتل
السادات السادات قتل ليه قتل بسبب انتشار
قوي جدا الجماعات الاصوليه التي شجعها
للقضاء على اسطوره او على الجسي بتاع جمال
عبد الناصر وهذه الجماعات زي وحش
فرانكشتاين
التهمت من اطلقها يعني ولقي مبارك عنده
اجنده ثانيه اقتصاد متداعي
وعنده جماعات متطرفه فظل في حرب هذه
الجماعات لسنوات
ثم محاوله انعاش الاقتصاد قدر ما يستطيع
يعني نجح ح بعض الانجازات وحقق اخفاقات
وظلت مصر لا لا يعني لا
يعني لا تطفو ولا تغرق
ا جت ثوره 11 يناير وشفنا ما حدث يعني وثم
جاء الرئيس وجاء الرئيس محمد مرسي ثم حصلت
حصل استقطب كبير في المجتمع المصري وبعدين
جاء الرئيس السيسي الرئيس السيسي تبع
برنامج ادى الى وجود بعض المشروعات المهمه
والانجازات جيده ولكن كان بتكلفه عاليه
جدا واستدان كبيره جدا جدا جدا قعدتنا
للمربع يعني رقم واحد وتظل مشكله مصر انها
بلد غير جاذب للاستثمار نستطيع ان نبني
مدنا نستطيع ان نبني طرقا لكن مش قادرين
نجذب لا نقنع المستثمر المحلي انه يدخ
اموال بتكفي ولا قادرين نقنع المستثمر
الاجنبي ان ياتي ويدخ استثمارات كبيره
حقيقيه ودي مشاكل تحتاج في علاجها لاراده
سياسيه قويه جدا ورؤيه واضحه وتخطيط
والكلام يطول عن هذا الامر يعني
[موسيقى]
فالمسالة مش لان هو لا سمح الله يعني مش
معروف انا ده تقصير من عندي يعني
ا عدد من الاصدقاء الاكراد المحترمين يعني
ا ممكن استضافه احدهم بالمانع كيف سمحت
الولايات
المتحده كيف سمحت الولايات المتحده لروسيا
بالنهوض من جديد بعد تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي الولايات المتحده ولا اي دوله
بتسمح لدوله بالنهوض ولا بالسقوط يعني
طبعا اذا كانت مصالحها يعني انما هي بتبقى
مزيج يعني ان الدوله نفسها لازم يكون ليها
دور انما ردا على سؤالك في الحاله الروسيه
بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان في كان في حاله ابتهاج لدى
الولايات المتحده واعتقدوا انه يعني لم
يعد هناك اي خطر يهدد السياده الامريكيه
على كامل العالم وظهرت كتابات
يعني زي كتاب اظن فرانسيس فو كياما اللي
هو كتب دي اند اوف هيستري انه خلاص ان
دوره التاريخ توقفت وان النموذج الامريكي
هيسود العالم كله وكان التصور فيما يتعلق
بروسيا كان في توجهين توجه داخل البيت
الابيض بيقو ديك تشني انه مادام فككنا
الاتحاد السوفيتي لا يجب ان نفلت هذه
الفرصه وعلينا ان نفكك الدوله الروسيه ما
انت عندك الاتحاد السوفيتي بكل دوله
المختلفه ال 14 اظن وعندك كان اهم دوله
فيهم والدوله الكبرى فيهم هي روسيا
الاتحاديه روسيا الاتحاديه ماهش بلد زي
مصر او المغرب دي دوله يعني دول كتيره
يعني مجموعه اعراق كتيره و ودول كتيره
تجمعت في الاتحاد الروسي اللي هو اكبر
مساحه اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث المساحه
اكثر من 17 مليون كيلو متر مربع وعلشان
تتخيلوا مساحه ال 17 م م مربع دول اكبر
دوله في العالم
العربي وفي افريقيا هي الجزائر
2.8 مليون ي مر مربع مصر دوله مساحتها
متوسطه بنتكلم على مليون كيل متر مربع
روسيا قدها 17 مره على كل الاحوال كان في
توجه قاد ديك تشيني ده مسجل في اجتماعات
يعني البيت الابيض ووثائق امريكيه منشوره
ما لم تع سرا بانه يجب ننتهز الفرصه ونفك
الاتحاد الروسي دهما كان في تصور ثاني ا
قادوا الرئيس جورج
بوش الاب يعني بانه لسنا في حاجه الى ذلك
وانه هيحصل مخاطر انتشار اسلحه نوويه هتقع
في ايدي دويلات لا نعرف توجهاتها واسلحه
خطيره غير نوويه هتقع في ايدي جماعات
ويبقى في عنف وقتل وعدم استقرار يهدد
المصالح الامريكيه وع ايه كانوا سعداء جدا
بوجود دوله الاتحاد الروسي تحت قيادات زي
جورباتشوف ثم يلتسن اللي هي كانت خصوصا
يلتسن يعني اللي بيعتبروه الان في روسيا
رجل الغرب في روسيا فكانوا يتوقعوا ان هذا
سوف يستمر ولكن جاء بوتين وتغيرت
الامور هل لد حضرتك اي تفسير مقنع لبقاء
صحافه معارضه لاذاعه لاذاعه مثل مدى مصر
تعمل بدون غلق الى الان من داخل مصر بل
هناك خروج من حديث
لصحافة
الشيء الذي لا يتم انكاره انه سقف الحريات
في مصر منخفض جدا هذا لا جدال عليه وما
اعتقدش ان في حد بيجادل فيه انما برضو في
نفس الوقت هو عمليه نسبيه مصر وما كانتش
يعني في معظم الاحوال
يعني يعني
شديده القمع بحيث ان كل واحد يقول كلمه
لازم يعني يتم سجنه ويتم غلقه لا مش بهذه
مش بهذه الصوره يعني وكان في تعبير لطيف
لاحد المؤرخين المهتمين بمصر او الكتاب
المهتمين بالشان المصري لا اذكر اسمه الان
ققول مصر دايما كانت تختلف عن العراق
وسوريا انها دول فيها مايلد ديكتر شيبس
يعني
ديكتاتوريات متوسطه او حميده او مش عنيفه
قوي فارس منور الله يحفظك ويخليك اهلا
استاذ سيد ارجو ان تعطينا ده شا تعطينا
اسماء افضل المواقع والكتب قنوات اليوتيوب
لتعلم الاقتصاد باحترافيه بالانجليزيه كما
وعدتني ما انا قلت والله يا شادي في
الحلقه الماضيه لا مش في الحلقه الماضيه
انت يعني كان في اصدقاء قالو لي وانا قلت
لهم على بعض المواقع مدام بتعرف لغه
انجليزيه مش هيكون عندك مشكله في اي حاجه
يعني في كتب في مواقع كتيره للمبتدئين
يعني كل انفستوبيديا يعني لو كتبت
انفستوبيديا اللي هي موسوعه في يعني مش
موسوعه هو موقع مسمي نفسه كده
في بيعلم الناس
من الابجديات يعني في بالانس موقع برض جيد
بيعلم الناس من
الابجديات في موقع والله مش فاكر اسمه
اسمه استدي حاجه دي دوت ك حاجه بيعلم
الطلبه بس بق ده في متنوعه لكن منهم
الاقتصاد برضو بيعلم في حاجه عاوز اقوللك
عليه يعني انا قلت لك الاتنين دول اهو
بالانس جيد وعندك انفستوبيديا ده برض جيد
وفي احيانا بتبقى طريقه ان
انت تكتب السؤال وتكتب 1 او 1 او سمبلي
فايد ما 1 او و يعني للمبتدئين
فبتلاكي
مواقع جيده برضو او احيانا جرايد محترمه
يعني انت عندك مثلا الايكونومست بتعمل
حاجات للمبتدئين بتعمل تعريفات اساسيه
يعني
يعني اذا ما كنتش افدتك بلغني وانا معاك
انا تحت
امرك بس بالمناسبه انت لازم تحدد برض هدفك
الاقتصاد كتير اللي انا قلت لك عليه ده
كما فهمت من سؤالك للمبتدئين عاوز يعرف
يعني الف ب اقتصاد وسوء مال الى اخره يعني
مرحبا استاذ
سيد جري
ا اعمل فيك ايه يا جون جري جري جري ري اه
العب ده عندك انت ولا عند انا اوعى تقول
لي عندي عندك خصم
اسبوع مرحبا استاذ سيد تحياتي لك من نابلس
المقاومه تعلمنا من قناتك الكريمه ان
العلاقات الدوليه مليئه بالتناقضات ده
صحيح ده اخونا عمرو ولكن اريد ان افهم كيف
تفسر تناقض دعم دويله قطر لقطاع غزه
المحكوم من حماس بالرغم من
عداوه من عداوه حاجه مش واضحه بالنسبه لي
يعني انا بالنسبه لي اقول قطر يعني مش
هستخدم اللغه بتاعتك هذه على مسؤوليتك انت
او ده رايك انت كل الاحترام ليه ولكن قطر
دوله زي الامارات زي كل الدول زي البحرين
انا اجبت على السؤال ده تقريب المره اللي
فاتت وبعد كده يعني بسبب الالحاح في
السؤال فانا خدت السؤال وحطيته على صفحه
القناه كيف تجمع قطر ما بين دعمها لحماس
وفي نفس الوقت تحالفها مع الولايات
المتحده هي متحالفه مع الولايات المتحده
رسميا هي دوله بتحض بامتيازات الدول
المتحالفه مع الولايات المتحده خارج الحلف
الشمالي الاطلسي واراضيها مفتوحه قاعدتين
امريكيتين كبار كل ده لا يخفى على
احد وهي علاقتها جيده باسرائيل لانها
بتلعب دور الوسيط لا يمكن ان تكون وسيطا
وعلاقتك باسرائيل علاقه سيئه ولكن السبب
انا قلته في الحلقه اللي فاتت
و كنت قلته من اربع سنين في حلقه بنفس
العنوان ماذا تريد قطر و ببساطه
انه انه قطر قررت كده لاسباب يطول شرحها
ان هي تكون دوله بالاضافه لامكانيات
الضخمه لازم يكون ليها وزن سياسي هذا
الوزن السياسي اكتسبته قطر من ان تكون
وسيطا في كثير من النزاعات وخصوصا
النزاعات ما بين الدول الكبيره وما بين
الجماعات الاسلاميه بكل
انواعها وعشان هي تقوم بدور الوسيط لازم
تكون وسيطه الوسيط ده يكون مقبول من
الطرفين من الولايات المتحده من اوروبا
هذا اسرائيل هذا يعني مثلا حلف ولازم بقى
طالبان والاخوان المسلمين وحماس والجهاد
وحشد الشعب تكون هي مقبوله ليهم هتكون
مقبوله ازاي من الولايات المتحده ما لم
تكن تقدم خدمات للولايات المتحده باستضافه
مثلا قواعدها وهتكون مقبوله من حماس ازاي
اذا لم تكن تقدم لها دعما وتستضيف قادتها
فده دور حماس مرحبا به والولايات المتحده
مرحبه ب وهذا الدور اللي بتلعبه قطر لما
بنقول الدور اللي بتلعبه قطر مش كلمه
يعني دور ما سويسرا بتلعب دور
سويسرا لسنوات طويله في ظروف تاريخيه قررت
ان هي تبقى دوله وسيط حبيب للكل يه اسباب
يطول شرحها ممكن نتكلم فيها لو انتم
مهتمين انما اصل كلمه دور عامله زي كلمه
اجن احيانا يدي دلالات سلبيه لا هو دور
اختارته قطر ورحبت به الدول الغربيه كانت
ممكن تطلبه قطر وتفشل
فيه يعني اظن هذه هي الاجابه واتمنى ان
تكون وصلت لحضرتك وارجع للي انا قلته
لحضرتك ارجع لصفحه القناه واكتب قطر
هتطلعلك الحلقه القديمه فيها تصوري يعني
المتواضع لسياسه قطر الخارجيه وفي ملخصها
برض موجود في حوالي دقيقتين كده
الشاشه سوداء يا
شباب بيقولولي الشاشه
سوداء انا ايه حسدتكم ولا
ايهال ايه الحكايه طب انت اعمل انت عندك
لايت اخونا احمد ما توقعاتك لنهايه حرب
غزه هذا هو السؤال الاصعب واللي انا كنت
معتقد انه هيكون موضوع الحل
الرئيسي اللي بيسال السؤال ده
سمر اذا كنت قريته او سامر انا مش متاكد
سامر اعتقد
سامر الحرب الحرب اذا كنت بتتكلم على
العسكريا ف يعني تصور اسرائيل للحرب انا
بتكلم على تصور اسرائيل الاول معلن واظن
ان كلامها بينس جم مع تصرفاتها هي قالت ان
انا بدات المرحله الثالثه ما هي المرحله
الاولى والمرحله الثانيه
المرحله الاولى كان
قسف عنيف جدا بالطيران في محاوله للتمهيد
ان هي تسكت اكبر يعني كميه ممكنه من نيران
المقاومه تسكتها يعني تدمر اكبر مصادر
للنيران وهكذا بتفعل اسرائيل وهكذا بتفعل
الولايات المتحده كاستراتيجيه عسكريه في
اي حرب ليه بيعملوا كده امكانيات ضخمه
وعدم رغبه في او قدره او تولرنس يعني ل
للخسائر
البشريه على العكس الدول اللي هي
امكانيتها اقل ممكن تضحي بشبابها لكن ما
تضحي بفلوسها لان فلوسها مش موجوده طيب
المرحله الثانيه كانت الغزو البري اللي
بدا اظن في 27 اكتوبر
الماضي الاتنين محققوش الاهداف اللي بتقول
عليها اسرائيل لا هم يعني حيدوا الخطر
حماس والجهاد والمقاومه بصفه عامه ولا هم
استعادوا اسراهم ولا غيره يعني لكن قالوا
طيب هنبدا المرحله الثالثه بقى والمرحله
الثالثه دي عباره عن عمليات نوعيه
والنوعيه دي هتبقى بالطيران
وبالقصر صلاح
العاروري وانه
يستهدف يضرب عمليه هنا يضرب عمليه هناك
اعتمادا على تفوق الجو من الناحيه
واعتمادا على ما يقول انها تبقى معلومات
استخباراتيه دقيقه هل ينجح ام لا طبعا هو
لما عمل القصه ديت عملها الاسباب انتقل
للمرحله الثالثه لعده اسباب اولها انه
مستحيل يفضل يستانف عمليات عسكريه بهذا
القدر من الكثافه لان هو كان قام باستدعاء
بالاضافه للقوات النظاميه ل 300000 رقم
كبير جدا جدا بالنسبه
ل دوله الاحتلال اللي عدد
سكانها ت ونص مليون منهم 20 مليون عربي
اظن ما فيش منهم حد بيخش الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعني واذا حد فيهم دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
تتبقى حاجه استثنائيه يعني فده عدد كبير
جدا هو مضطر انه يلجا
ل للمرحله الثالثه اللي هي تبقى ما يسميها
بعمليات نوعيه عشان هؤلاء المجندين اولا
يرجعوا للحياه الاقتصاديه التي تاثرت
كثيرا اثنين لتخفيف حده الانتقادات
الدوليه بسبب كثافه القتل العشوائي
للمدنيين وليس لحماس يعني ولا للمقاومه
ا لاثه ان هو محققش برض اللي هو كان عاوزه
كتير يعني ف توقعات ل نهايه الحرب ان هي
سوف تستمر لفتره طويله لكن حرب لو انتنستي
وور حرب منخفضه الكثافه اذا اردت مثالا
للو انتنستي ور انظر الى الحرب اللي
موجوده في اليمن مافيش الحرب ما انتهتش في
اليمن ولا حاجه ولكن احنا بنتكلم على حرب
منخفضه الكث كثافه يعني ما انتهتش رسميا
يعني انما مستقبل غزه بقى اذا سالتوا عليه
انا تحت امركم ماشي لماذا دائما من يتولى
الحكم في اغلب بلادنا العربيه يكون اسوا
من ابناء الشعب على الرغم من ان بلادنا
بها الكثير من الاشخاص المثقفين مثل حضرتك
والاقتصاديين والسياسيين وال العلماء ده
ابراهيم انا مش متاكد يعني من مقوله اذا
كانت شرشل كان قال كده فعلا ولا لا ولكن
اظن انه الكلام دقيق انه يعني انه كل شعب
يعني بيحكموا من يستحقه من يستحق هذا
الشعب احنا عندك انت يعني بتحمل
ال يعني
بتحمل الحكام احيانا ما لا يحتملون هي في
اخطاء عند الحكام وفي اخطاء عند الناس
يعني ما انت عندك ثقافه شعب انا شفت بنفسي
مش انا شفت انا قريت يعني بس انا اقصد
اقول حتى في التلفزيون في البرامج العاديه
مجموعه من الشيوخ
ومشاهير الشيوخ اللي موجودين مثلا في مصر
وما ينطبق على هؤلاء ينطبق على غيرهم هم
كانوا قالوا بالنص كده انه لا يصح ابدا
ابدا الخروج على حاكم انا ما بتكلمش على
حاجه سر والله انتوا ممكن تفتحوا مثلا ده
ده مثلا
راي الشيخ خالد الجندي وهو رجل مثلا معالم
دين مشهور ودكتور رمضان اظن كان معاه
واخرين وكلهم من مشاهير وقالوا كده قالوا
لا يصح الخروج على حاكم لانها تخرج على
حاكم ازاي هذه اراده الله هو ياتي بمن
يشاء الى الحكم ويذهب بمن يشاء ان الحكم
يعني يؤتي الحكم يؤتي الملك من يشاء
وبالتالي وعليه فانه مافيش دي اراده الله
انه جاء بهذا الحاكم الى بلد ما ولا يصح
ان تعارض مشيئه الله هل الكلام ده هم
اخترعوه من عندهم ده يعني ثقافه موجوده
ويدعمها علماء بشهادات باحاديث وقران فدي
جزء من ثقافه ناس
ا يعني الحاكم برض لما بيجي ما هو بيستن
الى نخب فاسده يعني نخب مستفيده وكان
استاذنا العالم الكبير جدا جدا جدا
الدكتور محمد دويدار وهو واحد من العلماء
الكبار رحمه الله مات هذا العام يعني مات
عام
2023 كان ما فهمتش لما كان بيقول لي انه
الطبقه المتوسطه او النخب المثقفه هو كان
بيتكلم على الطبقه المتوسطه يعني بانها
نخبه خائنه ايه الطبقه المتوسطه في تعريفه
اللي هي يعني طبقه المهنيين اللي
هم بيساعدوا دائما السلطات وبيحكم صحفيين
واعلاميين سياسيين الى اخره لانه دول
بيفضلوا مصالحهم على مصالح الاخرين عموما
دي قصه يطول
شرحها و
الشعوب بتحتاج كتير قوي علشان تتطور يعني
نفس الكلام كان موجود ده اللي بيدينا
الامل كان موجود في دول اوروبيه كتير الى
ان تطورت احوالهم
يعني كيف نفهم الموقف السعودي من القضيه
الفلسطينيه لماذا لا يكون للسعوديه دور
ريادي على الموقف العربي
ا جرمون اذا كنت مس جرمون ا
هو الموقف السعودي كما افهمه انه عنده
مشكله يعني ان هو مش مبتهج بانه حماس اولا
هو له موقف سلبي من حماس وهو ليس وحده
يعني السعوديه مش لوحدها اللي عندها موقف
من حماس لكن انت بتسالني عن حماس هو ما
كانش يتمنى انه يجد ان كل مخططاته اي تبقى
رهينه لقرار جماعه هو لا يحبها ويختلف
معها ويكون اسيرا لها بمعنى تخيل كده هو
عنده مشكله مع جماعه حماس والاخوان
المسلمين كلهم واحد فده في حد ذاته يخليه
مستاء انه هذه الجماعه تفرض عليه اجندتها
بهجوم او بقرار هو لم يستشار فيه ده واحد
اثنين انه حماس مش بس بتمثل مشكله او خطر
او تهديد على السعوديه ده خطرها بيزيد ان
هي داعمه الرئيسي هو ايران اللي هي بتمثل
خصما للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبديه انه
طالما طالما ده طالما ايران هي داعمه
الرئيسي هتكون حلفائها مين هيكون حلفائها
حزب الله وهتكون جماعه الحوثي وجماعه
الحشد الشعبي اللي هم كل حلفاء ايران في
المنطقه اللي هم بيمثلوا خطرا على المملكه
العربيه
السعوديه ثم انه بقى ده بصفه عامه وبصفه
خاصه قرار حماس بالهجوم على او بحرب 7
اكتوبر ده اربك حسابات السعوديين اللي
كانوا ماشيين في اتجاه تاني خالص الاتجاه
الثاني خالص ده هو اتمام عمليه تسويه في
المنطقه انا يقيني هم بيقولوا ان هم كانوا
هيحافظوا على حقوق السعوديين هم ادرى بذلك
وكل الاحترام لهمم لكن انا كان تقديري ان
هذه الحقوق هتكون شكليه وفي حدها الادنى
لانه زي ما بنقول في مصر الحدايه لا تلقي
كتاكي الحدايه ما بترش كتاكيت اسرائيل مش
هتدي لحد حاجه
ولكن كان تخيل السعوديه انه التسويه
مرتبطه بحاله الهدوء اللي سبقت 7 اكتوبر
وكان يبقى في نوع من التطبيع مع اسرائيل
وتحصل السعوديه على كل المطالب اللي هي
طلبتها من الامريكان واتكلمنا عنها قبل
كده برنامج نووي متطور ا ابواب مفتوحه
لمستودعات الاسلحه المتقدمه للولايات
المتحده ثم باكت مكتوب اتفاق مكتوب ضمانات
امنيه تمنح للسعوديه من الولايات المتحده
على غرار ما تمنحه امريكا بحلفائها في حلم
شمال الاطلسي كل ذلك تعرقل وع الاقل مؤقتا
يعني ثم انه برضو العمليه صبت من وجهه نظر
السعوديه في صالح ايران وهذا لا يسعد
السعوديين الصوت لم يكن واضحا مساء الخير
ارجو اعاده الجواب ما هو على اي سؤال يا
صديقي حسب قراءتك كيف كانت اداره حكومه
بشار للاقتصاد
السوري ح لا ده سؤال محتاج جيده ام سيئه
هو الاقتصاد السوري كان جيد يعني بصفه
عامه بس ده محتاج يعني الاسئله اللي هي
محتاجه مراجعه يعني
انما يعني الاقتصاد سوري كان وصل
لاكتر من 200 مليار دولار في 2010 و21
واظن تجاوز ال 200 مليار دولار وده رقم
بالنسبه لتعداد سوريا السكاني يعني رقم
جيد
جدا لكن
الاجابه وبصفه عامه كان عنده قدر كبير من
الاكتفاء الذاتي في قطاعات مختلفه اظن ان
الاجابه الاقتصاد اول ان اول كان جيدا
يعني لم يكن سيئا
هل تعتقد ان اسرائيل قادره على تنفيذ
مرادها وتهجير سكان قطاع
غزه ده مصطفى الحبيب اظن ان اسرائيل
بتحاول على
صعيدين وهو ده بياخدنا للسؤال اللي انا
كنت طرحته على حضراتكم مستقبل
غزه مستقبل غزه في في تقديري كده طبعا لا
يعلمه الا الله مش يعني مش يعني لا يعلم
كل حاجه لا يعلمها الا الله طبعا في
المستقبل ولكن الحقيقه ان مافيش حد عنده
تصور واضح حتى يعني يعني ممكن يكون الناس
عندها تصور وفي الاخر المستقبل يتغير لا
ما فيش لا علم ولا تصور لكن المؤكد الاتي
انه من
الصعب ان تعود قطاه غزه كما كان قبل يوم 7
اكتوبر ليس من المتصور ان اسرائيل تستطيع
ان تقضي على حماس كما قالت لكن ليس من
المتصور ان تعود حماس لحكم القطاع وكان
شيئا لم يحدث ليه لانه عشان تحكم حماس
لازم تكون في مؤسسات
موجوده وقيادات بتمارس عملها في حاله
القذف وعمليه الاستهداف المستمره والعزله
من الدول الكبيره هيكون ده صعب ده واحد
اثنين اسرائيل
بتسعى من ناحيه تانيه لتنفيذ مخطط التهجير
على مستويين اقناع عدد من الدول
باستقبال اكبر عدد من الفلسطينيين والضغط
على دول اخرى لتحقيق نفس الغايه
وبتعزف بان هي تخلي الحياه في قطاع غزه لا
تحتمل ودي خطه قديمه واذكركم انه كان نعوم
شومسكي بيحذر
هذا العالم العبقري يعني كان بيحذر بانه
غزه بحلول عام 2020 و21 لن تكون صالحه
للسكنى فوهم بيسعوا في هذا المخطط يبقى من
ناحيه تانيه بيخلي الحياه غير قابله
للاستمرار في غزه و بيقنع دول ان هم
يفتحوا ابوابهم للغزاوي دي محاولات هل
تنجح هل تفشل تقديري انه حتى لا قدر الله
لو نجحت هتبقى عمليه بطيئه جدا جدا جدا
جدا
جدا ما لم تحدث
مفاجات
لماذا من الصعب على الدول الاستفاده من
ثرواتها بمعنى مع العولمه وتوفر راس المال
وجود الشركات متتعدده الجسات بيصعب على
الدول الافريقيه استخراج ثرواتها لا يا
عبد الرحمن هو مش هو الدول بيسهل ان هي
تستخرج ثرواتها لكن العائد منها محدود
يعني لما بتيجي شركه شركات متعدده
الجنسيات اي حاجه من الحاجات او يعني اي
شركات متعدده او غيره الشركات دي هي عندها
التكنولوجيا وهي عندها الاموال الاستثمار
وانت دورك يكون محدود جدا خصوصا ان انت
فقير يعني فقير وفاسد يعني ما الدول اللي
انت بتشير اليها دي مش بس فقيره فقيره
وفاسده فهم الشركات دي بجي ت تراض النخب
اللي موجوده وبتحصل على عقود للاستفاده من
هذه الثروات النحاس والحديد واليورانيوم
كل حاجه في مقابل زهيد جدا بيصل الى
الخزانه العامه للدوله وجزء اكبر بيروح
للنخب اللي هي بتاخذ الامتيازات وبتاخذ
مقابل
يعني الرشاوى او تحت الترابيزه في مقابل
منح العقود لشركات معينه والفتات بيذهب
الى الخزانه العامه
للدوله كيف قطر تدعم حماس ولديها قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه انا اجبت على هذا السؤال
لو كان هذا السؤال هو السؤال اللي ما كانش
واضح لما الصوت كان غير
واضح فاستاذنتها
ماذا تريد قطر فيها اجابه وفيها على
السؤال مسجله من اربع سنوات والاسبوع اللي
فات انا اجبت عليه في نفس البث المباشر
اللي هو كان الاسبوع اللي فات وخدت
المقتطف ده وانا حطه على صفحه القناه
بعنوان كيف تجمع قطر بين تحالفها او
علاقتها القويه بامريكا واسرائيل ودعمها
لحماس لماذا تكتفي مصر بدور البواب فقط في
ابعد الحالات مساعده لدوله قط في التفاوض
لا هذا مش سليم وده يعني نوع من اذا كنت
مصري فانت بتبقى واحد من المصريين اللي هو
قاسي جدا في استخدامه لانه بينتظر انه ودي
على فكره ظاهره بين المصريين ماعرفش في
دول تانيه دايما يقلل من ال